joe biden and donald trump are the exact
same person our entire lives as a
society we are taught republicans on one
side democrats on the other there's a
line in the sand pick your fighter well
guess what the more and more that i've
started to think about this they're the
exact same people both joe biden and
donald trump they do the same things
they say the same things and regardless
of what the mainstream media wants you
to believe you need to start thinking
for yourself so let's get into a couple
of the examples to prove that joe biden
and donald trump are the same person
first we can start out remember when
donald trump was in office and war three
was trending we were gonna go to war
with iran well now just this week world
war three was trending again this time
with joe biden and his thoughts around
possibly going to war with russia and
the ukraine situation under both
presidencies world war iii was trending
on twitter regardless of what country
we're talking about regardless of what
conflict we're talking about both
presidents on both sides of the aisle
world war three concerns from the public
trending on twitter then let's move on
and let's go ahead and let's look at
covet remember all the [ __ ] that
everyone was giving donald trump saying
he didn't control the pandemic he didn't
control kovitt19 well neither did joe
biden neither one of them did better
than the other the pandemic continued to
rage on this is from the beginning of
covet 19 until today cases continue to
increase throughout it doesn't matter
who the president is the virus does not
care who's in office it simply was going
to continue to do what the virus is
going to continue to do and so donald
trump failed and so did joe biden they
both failed to control a global pandemic
then we can look at spending of course
regardless of who's in office whether
it's a republican or a democrat they
continue to spend more and more and more
bill clinton george bush barack obama
and donald trump donald trump 28.4
trillion dollars on the national debt
well what about joe biden he's going to
come and solve this right no we now are
at almost 30 trillion dollars it doesn't
matter regardless of donald trump joe
biden republican or democrat they're all
the same the debt continues to increase
because nobody actually cares but of
course some may say well isn't it just
that donald trump and the way that he
used to operate the way that he used to
talk to the media that is what people
had the problem with it wasn't the
policies it's just that he was an
[ __ ] well let's look at this remember
this ridiculous tweet from donald trump
happy new year to everyone including the
haters and the fake news media 2019 will
be a fantastic year for those not
suffering from trump derangement
syndrome just calm down and enjoy the
ride great things are happening for our
country sounds ridiculous sounds
abrasive towards the haters sounds
ridiculous when he starts talking about
the fake news media right well just
yesterday joe biden literally called a
reporter a son of a [ __ ] and so
ultimately it doesn't matter who's in
office it doesn't matter if it's donald
trump doesn't matter if it's joe biden
they both don't like the media they both
look down on the media regardless if you
call it the fake news media or you call
the reporter a son of a [ __ ] they both
are the same exact
people then if we continue when we look
remember kovid 19 and how we were
talking about the racist travel ban how
donald trump was a racist well joe biden
literally implemented the same exact
travel bans he went to african countries
and said you cannot travel to the united
states that doesn't actually make either
one of them racist they were doing the
best that they could in terms of the
public health crisis but it doesn't
matter if it's donald trump doesn't
matter if it's joe biden they do the
same things they say the same things and
joe biden and donald trump are the exact
same people so stop listening to the
public narrative stop letting the
mainstream media absolutely become
divisive in terms of turning people that
are americans against each other instead
remember to think for yourself be a
critical independent thinker and
understand that regardless of who's in
office republican or democrat joe biden
or donald trump they're all the same
people